Nicole is with us in Flint Michigan hi
Nicole welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
how I would thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
well we just started SPU and we are on
class number four and I'm feeling very
overwhelmed on where I've started I know
you've laid out the baby steps
however we are behind on bills and we
have pretty high payments due to our
credit support not being great and so
I'm wondering should we deal with what
is out debt collectors right now which
is totally only like $1,100 so it could
be done rather quickly or should we just
stick with the steps and what are you
that's the only thing you're behind on
is eleven hundred dollars worth of that
well we have on our credit reports right
now about eleven hundred dollars worth
of items that we need to get cleaned up
so we can get our credit score up going
in the right direction what did you miss
in Financial Peace University that made
you think you need to get your credit
score up well right now I'm looking at
the big picture I'm trying to the big
picture should be that you don't need to
get your credit score up I know you're
caught you're focusing on the wrong
thing
okay the right thing the right thing is
let's get some money who gives a rip
about your credit score well I know I'm
a photographer and I need like a fifteen
thousand dollar business alone - really
Joe no you don't make more money that's
what I keep thinking only you don't need
a loan to make more money say well the
reason you're overwhelmed is I guess
you're going to go back through and
listen to some of those lessons again
you just said you went through number
four so you've been through dumping debt
yeah well no it's okay we just said the
snowball okay I spent my life doing the
money budget for the month okay you did
the debt snowball what do you mean that
that is that lesson you know we just
said the monthly budget planning oh I'm
sorry
University this will help you okay
Financial Peace University is all about
never born
again and getting out of that and that
would include not needing a credit score
and not using a loan to grow your
business and your so you're going to
find a way to make more money without
granting alone sure what about those
high interest rates okay we're going to
play long they're gonna be zero okay
what do you owe money on well we have
our truck with 21,000 I'm leasing a
vehicle and then we have about fifteen
thousand dollars in other miscellaneous
like loans and that's it we are lynn
contracting our home which is at sixty
thousand all right and your household
income is what our annual is sixty nine
thousand because the truck needs to be
sold keep telling my husband that the
truck payments six hundred and twenty
one dollars seventeen percent interest
yeah no it's good I know I know it's
sickening
all these Carly's car probably gotta go
to yeah our lease is up there way I'm
certain my payments on that hopefully we
can do at least Paul ahead just run
ahead and you know just go ahead and get
through that and and make sure you've
got a couple thousand bucks to buy you a
beater when your lease runs out and
let's get on his truck because here's
the thing y'all been borrowing on
everything in sight yep for years yep
years and years and so this is a
dramatic it's gonna it's gonna feel
strange to turn around and do an exact
hundred and eighty degree turn away from
the way you've been living for the last
decade it's gonna feel weird but when
you do there is gonna be an emotional
freedom to it right now you're still
have all this angst because you're
trying to fix it in your mind when you
called me the way you've always tried to
fix it and it doesn't work and I'm alone
in there so it's pretty it's pretty hard
because I'm constantly running through
this on my own
are you alone in it what's his problem
but you just have never been involved
the way of helping me with the bill
that's wrong - it's time for him to get
involved tonight is our first monthly
sit down guy is he going to the class
with you he has a key has attended two
of them with me he he gave me three
first one but he jumped on board for
number two and number three no good
research is now gonna provide child care
for us good that doesn't give him any
cookie I'm wonderful wonderful yeah yeah
so you get him on board
you guys stop borrowing money you
amputate some of the stupidity by
selling off some of these cars and stuff
you're gonna get you're not gonna be
overwhelmed anymore six weeks from now
your life is gonna feel dramatically
different six months from now it's gonna
be dramatically different if you'll do
the stuff I teach you to do okay and you
can do that so we're gonna grow our
income we're gonna stop our spending cut
a bunch of this stuff out and you know
you may not got eleven hundred bucks out
that may be part of it or you may need
that eleven hundred bucks to get you a
car and then you go back and clean that
stuff up later you're gonna get to it
it's just a matter which one you get to
first which one you get to second you
just got it aside that so a good
question you keep at it if you got more
questions you let me know make sure he's
in class with you it's absolutely vital
and he's on the same page so you're not
in this alone anymore
that's a big part of whether you make it
through this this is the Dave Ramsey
show
[Music]